Bentornati
è mica troppo questo per Youtube? è troppo questo? no perché
io quest'anno voglio dare il 110 per cento per il mio canale, perché, perché non si sa mai non si
sa mai perché Youtube ha cambiato, per esempio, l'algoritmo, un'altra volta e tutti i miei video potrebbero all'improvviso sparire nel nulla
e quindi ho voluto fare questo, ho voluto
regalarmi e regalarvi questa cosa qui, questo splendore, perché, non si sa mai non si
sa mai perché potrei morire da un momento all'altro e lasciare niente sul canale
perché potrebbe arrivare un fan e farmi la " John Lennonata" nel senso che arriva e dice: "Tu sei Yotobi?" "Si"
"Facciamo una foto?"
Benvenuti in Adrian
Ebbene si oggi siamo qui per parlare di una delle più grandi catastrofi della televisione italiana negli ultimi
dieci anni
lunedì 21 gennaio 2019 è andata in onda la prima puntata
di Adrian la Serie Evento; so che molti di voi l'hanno vista, ma moltissimi altri
Hanno soltanto visto quello che I loro amici hanno condiviso su facebook
sappiate che quella è soltanto la punta dell'iceberg
Tra l'altro,  dell'iceberg che ha fatto affondare il Titanic
Immaginatevi al posto del Titanic Mediaset, e al posto del capitano Smith Pier Silvio Berlusconi. Ecco,  adesso avete più o meno un immagine
di quello che è successo. Insieme a voi voglio
analizzare e sviscerare tutte le informazioni che abbiamo su questa serie e il capire perché sia
passata da serie evento a
cancellata dai palinsesti
Io sono qui, ho tutte le informazioni in mano e facciamo quasi una puntata di "Blu Notte".
Questo è Adrian: un mistero italiano.
[sigla]
Vorrei iniziare facendo un appello alla televisione italiana
basta!
basta rovinarci grandi miti della nostra infanzia! Io perché devo vedermi Claudio Baglioni, un'artista che portavo così quando ero piccolo,
sul palmo della mano, un'icona della musica leggera italiana
Dabbare a Sanremo nel 2019
Perché mi devo sorbire degli sketch che anche negli anni 50 sarebbero risultati antiquati
e così anche Adriano Celentano, il peter pan
della via Gluck.  Baglioni a Sanremo che Dabba e Celentano che fa una serie animata
su canale 5. Manca soltanto il canale di gameplay di De Andrè, dove tra l'altro fa soltanto reaction ai balli
di Fortnite, e il cazzo di filmino porno di Lucio Battisti, che invece di mandare il filmino
ad una ragazza in direct l'ha messo sulle stories per sbaglio. (Quest'immagine, bellissimo.) Quindi vi prego basta con questo massacro mediatico
detto questo possiamo iniziare
Le polemiche sulla serie partono già dal trailer
Celentano, lo spot di Adrian infastidisce gli spettatori: volume troppo molesto; che se lo vieni a chiedere a me
l'hanno deciso i vertici mediaset perché hanno visto in anteprima l'episodio, hanno notato che fosse
una merda e quindi hanno detto: "sai cosa facciamo? È troppo tardi per tirarci indietro, cerchiamo
di ammazzare tutti con un infarto, no?" tipo un moderno Deathnote. Poi arrivano le prime indiscrezioni, che dallo studio, durante le prove
Michelle Hunziker e Teo Teocoli se la telano.
E, leggendo queste notizie, io stavo già annusando il profumo del capolavoro, ovviamente,  però non ero ancora
convinto. Nello spendere un'intera sera a guardare questa cosa qui finché. Sulla pagina facebook ufficiale
Di celentano non è apparso un promo vi giuro su dio non ho mai visto
Uno spot più incredibile di questo adriano in bagno che si filma da solo mentre appare la sua versione animata
Davanti alla telecamere davanti. Allo specchio senza, una vera e propria prospettiva. Io ero in estasi. Mistica
Tanto che ho voluto contribuire al successo del progetto poco prima dell'uscita però
Arrivano, I numeri dieci anni di produzione e tra I 20 ei 30 milioni di euro
Di costi ora le notizie su questi dati sono molto molto molto confuse a quanto pare ci sono stati casini
nella produzione che l'hanno fatta saltare più volte dal 2009
insomma sono le caratteristiche per la prima serata su canale 5 e mediaset ha un
disperato bisogno di ascolti soprattutto dopo il flop
Dell'attesissimo ritorno della dottoressa, giorno doccia gelata per barbara. D'urso ed è per questo motivo prego che mi sono fatto stampare
Il cartonato dello share di adrian un po con tipo tipo memento mori. Ma tralasciando tutte queste informazioni
Le puntate in sé come sono grazie per avermelo chiesto cercherò di raccontarmi e di capire. I motivi per I quali
questa serie, sia, un caso mediatico nazionale
cercando di dividere tutto nelle quattro puntate non credo che andrò a fondo nelle puntate 1 perché mediaset che mi fa un
Così ma soprattutto perché le puntate
Ufficialmente non ci sono da nessuna parte né su mediaset play nei suoi infiniti
E fate conto che sui figli dice la dottoressa giò però se voleste recuperarli. Almeno il primo episodio
Qualcuno, l'ha caricato su hicks videos. Adrian the italian and buy
ma state attenti perché non ci sono scene
Di sesso esplicito come ricorda giustamente nei commenti del video arturia pendragon hentai non
Ho visto un cazzo in tutti I sensi
Francamente non mi sembra intaj. Se non si vede ma anche un rapporto sessuale
almeno si è visto le zinne
Grazie arturia
Ogni puntata è divisa in due parti il pre show ambientato in un teatro dove ci sono
Sketch e monologhi fatti da comici davanti ad un pubblico live e poi la serie animata vera e propria il pre show della prima puntata
Getta le basi per tutte le altre
Lento, noioso e veramente veramente credermi veramente tanto banale insieme a nino frassica si parla di immigrati
Cercando di ironizzare con. Uno sketch con l'arca di noè ma è talmente atroce
Nelle battute nelle tempistiche che tutto muore nei primi due cazzo. Di minuti poi arriva. Il monologo. Di natalino balasso
noi sappiamo le potenzialità che a natalino balasso e qual è il suo e
Quanto è bravo a fare il comico. Ma. Niente non basta. Neanche quello
Una merda su tutti I livelli satira vecchia su argomenti stanchi passano soltanto
Dieci minuti e su internet si scatena il finimondo
Una serie di commenti così negativa che mi ha ricordato un altro evento importante
Della, televisione italiana quando ciccio è stato invitato a a mai dire talk per chi non se lo ricordasse questa è un'immagine catturata
In quel momento è così esumate un attimo potete vedere ciccio vessato
Dalla, gialappa's e finalmente dopo un pochino arriva anche celentano
acclamato, dal pubblico solo che dice soltanto di numero 15 parole e va via e parte la serie animata e io
io mi sono messo nei panni
Di quei poveracci che sono stati invitati a teatro magari dicendogli osta per dopo sette anni sta per ritornare
adriano in tv vuoi far parte del pubblico dice cazzo sì il mio artista, preferito
e poi rimane seduto a guardare
52 minuti. Di una serie animata proiettata contro un muro a teatro e dopo dieci minuti
Di agonia live finalmente inizia il motivo per cui noi siamo qua e posso dirvi
Dal profondo del cuore che le aspettative sono state rispettate
La prima cosa che salta all'occhio sono, I disegni e le animazioni
Molti sul web l'hanno definita una merda animata malissimo disegnata ancora peggio ma
Secondo me non
È del tutto vero la verità è che in 52 minuti di episodio si passa dall'avere dei disegni
effettivamente dettagliati a delle bozze mai finite di vignette inesistente idem le animazioni fluide e
complesse anche in scene con numerosi personaggi, su schermo fino ad arrivare a
Delle, fotografie animate con il fluidificante photoshop a volte assomigliano. Spaventosamente
alle animazioni dell'orso malosso a monte assomigliano a quelle animazioni dei videogiochi
Porno che c'erano I primi anni del 2000 in flash. Quelle dove dovevi. Cliccare un tasto solo per far
contrastare l'idea 22
Personaggi per fargli fare sesso virtualmente io esatto ci. Giocavo un sacco solo in un secondo momento
arriva, in faccia al pubblico la trama molto confuso e molto molto noiosa riassumo brevemente
ambientata nel futuristico
2068 adrian è un orologiaio
Durante un concerto decide di prendere il posto del cantante e fare un pezzo. Sua diventa involontariamente famoso ma
Proprio per questo parte una caccia. All'uomo per mano del. Governo e tra l'altro il cantante di cui prende il posto
Sul palco che assomiglia vagamente ad un nemico. Di kenshiro e in realtà giuliano dei negramaro
Davvero, sta cantando mentre tutto scorre. Sul palco e adrian poi gli prende il posto non. So voi ma
Io sono veramente contento che nel 2000 e 68 gli unici due cantanti italiani sopravvissuti siano. Adriano. Celentano e I negramaro sono
Niente ma. Che peccato niente trap. Strano da questo pilot però sono uscite due chicche interessanti
Il viso di adriano a letto con
Claudia mori che sembra uno di quegli esperimenti dove un artista sotto 20 droghe diverse. Disegna 20 volte il suo volto
No qui, siamo verso I 10 mg. Di. Lory tab che dovrebbe essere derivanti
Della, codeina più o meno e poi l'ormai famosissima per I mini che sono stati creati
Casa con la palma che tra l'altro non so se lo sapete ma questo non è un disegno
Di milo manara come tutti
Gli altri concept della serie, ma questo è un disegno proprio fatto da adriano celentano e postato nel suo blog nel 2015 adriano
aggiornamento con scritto
Albero non essere così rigoglioso. Se non comune ti strangola
Poesia e io ho voluto mangiarti adriano facendo costruire tutto quanto è mannaggia e poi ovviamente non potevano mancare
ulteriori polemiche durante un pezzo di puntata ambientato a napoli
appare un edificio
chiamato mafia international
capitanato da da un uomo
Cattivissimo che si chiama grange style che una curiosissima fusione non sto scherzando è una crisi ma fusione tra
frankenstein e
Andrangheta ecco cosa mai potrebbe andare storto con la comunità italiana
facendo questo tipo di rappreseglia sociazione noi consumatori presenterà querela contro la trasmissione
Di canale 5 per la rappresentazione. Di napoli quale capitale. Di mafia international
Horse e che dopo tutto questo casino gli ascolti della puntata sono
Incredibilmente medi per essere il ritorno. Di celentano dopo sette anni di inattività in televisione ma
C'è una particolarità nel segmento iniziale del pre show. Quando appare. Lui siamo sui 5 milioni
997mila che circa il 22 per cento di share come dicevo medio per mediaset
ma quando inizia la serie animata si scende al
19,0 7 per cento a 4 milioni
544 mila spettatori praticamente perde un milione di spettatori questo mi fa capire la discrepanza di chi volesse vedere
Lui e di chi fosse effettivamente interessato al progetto animato
Nella parte line del secondo episodio
invitano giovanni storti che fa uno sketch con natalino balasso
Sempre sugli stessi argomenti attuali ma
Troppo ridondanti migranti reddito di cittadinanza quota 100 e così via adrian. Ha questo potere. Di rendere le persone potenzialmente
Divertenti in day cazzo di clown senza talento la serie animata invece sembra prendere la strada della noia
È nella, mia testa pensavo perfetto per me finisce qui. Se diventa solo per curare le animazioni disegni non
Ne vale la pena ma a un certo punto il twist si scopre che adrian di giorno aggiusta
Orologi. Di notte è un supereroe mascherato
Chiamato la volpe che se ne va in giro con questa maschera nera che assomiglia un po azzurro
Se devo dire più che un supereroe e tra l'altro
giorno in spagnolo vuol dire proprio
volpe quindi e zorro
Quindi e zorro con tutti cazzo di supereroi da cui potevano prendere spunto
Hanno, preso spunto dalle più noioso mai creato. Sulla faccia. Della terra che non. È manco italiano avessero
Preso spunto dai vecchi e dimenticati super eroi italiani che podlech fulmine supereroi. Italo. Americano del
Protagonista di avventure incredibili tra le quali la bottega del. Cinese il mistero del colon è l'indimenticabile
Rivolta negra e invece. No
Zorro ma non è questo il vero colpo di scena la volpe vede due ragazze che stanno per essere violentata in una scena anche abbastanza
Forte e le salva avrebbe potuto stare zitto salutare e andare via invece si
gira, le guarda negli occhi ancora scosse
Dal trauma e dice se avesse bevuto qualche bicchierino in meno forse avreste evitato
l'increscioso approccio con quei tipi loschi
Panico su internet esplode il cataclisma
ma mentre tutti gridavano
Giustamente allo. Scandalo io stavo applaudendo
dalla
Gioia perché in una maniera un po perversa era esattamente questo che volevo
Dudley con la serie non il classico. Trash da lavoro fatto male ma proprio essere fuori luogo ed è da quel momento
Che ho iniziato a prendere appunti. Lo share di questo secondo episodio
ricordandoci sempre che il pre show fa sempre circa un milioncino un milioncino e qualcosa in più se chiude al
13,20 6 per cento
2.887.000
Spettatori la meta quasi di quello. Della puntata precedente che non è andata in onda una settimana prima
ma il giorno
Prima in un giorno ha perso la metà degli spettatori che per un progetto costato tra. I
20 ei 30 milioni è durato dieci anni
non credo sia, accettato dai vertici mediaset
sopra si trema e piersilvio suda
Sapendo il putiferio che ha causato lo scorso episodio come affronteranno il problema
Con una delle più grandi
Paraculate che io abbia mai visto in vita mia
Chiamano un'attrice ilenia pastorelli che tra l'altro è anche. Molto brava e l'attrice che ha fatto
Ve la ricorderete probabilmente per lo chiamavano jeeg robot e le fanno fare. Monologo. Sulla violenza contro le donne
Collegata alla frase. Se l'è cercata a
Fanculo vogliono cercare di farci sentire in colpa per un problema che hanno creato. Loro sarebbe
Come urlare viva gli animali con un pezzo di cheeseburger che ti cade. Dalla bocca e stato un disastro
Ma. Ma la parte animata ha riservato una piccola gemma
Questo ed. Arianna e il travestimento che usa adrian. Nella serie per farsi catturare
D'aria adrian ha invertito le due lettere e ha messo il naso
una parrucca gli occhiali la gobba
Non lo so io volevo di fulmine contro il pugilatore
Mascherato e invece no mi devo sorbire, la befana andreotti. Ormai a quel punto lì o
fiutato la cancellazione e ho perso un po le speranze lo share è sceso al
10,55 per cento con 2 milioni a malapena gli spettatori e mancano ancora
sette puntate
Nella quarta puntata arriva al dramma
celentano non si presenta nel preshow tonfo adrian ascolti
Polverizzati celentano sparisce piersilvio ormai me lo immagino come il sottotenente
Di last action hero col fumo dalle orecchie al posto. Di adriano però appare
rientrare nell'arca perché miliardi e tutto mio non
So esattamente il perché probabilmente perché gigi sabani è morto anni fa e non è più disponibile poco prima
della, puntata animata arriva pure l'esibizione di un ballerino
Ucraino che ha la faccia di putin tatuata
Immenso, I pettorali cioè come sia una puntata di domenica in andasse ospite primo. Levi con una svastica tatuata
Sul petto tipo american history hicks la parte animata invece è in fase molto
Calante poca carne al fuoco ma. Un sacco di pipponi a due mani a celentano che si presenta come colui che aprì gli occhi
Alla, gente salva le menti. Di noi poveri ignoranti. Ma. Almeno
Abbiamo, una soluzione ad un enigma che va avanti da tre settimane
Qual, è lo studio che ha fatto le animazioni
Di adrian sono riuscito a trovare un vecchio articolo del 2005 del sito fanclub
di adriano celentano in cui c'è scritto che lo studio legato
Alle animazioni e lo studio sempre lo studio sec. È uno studio nord
Coreano che tra le tante cose a cui elaborato ci sono. Quelle sottomarche della disney tipo simba junior. Nella nazionale
Di calcio o cose simili ma soprattutto è
L'autore delle animazioni di due film di creazione italiana
sulla leggenda del titanic chiamati appunto la leggenda del titanic e
Tenta colino che si sia scoperto questa. Cosa qua è
Incredibile ma non solo passino le animazioni. Ok
Come mai, I disegni di milo manara a tratti siano. Così orrendi. Abbiamo la risposta
Anche. Di questo perché. Come ogni mistero italiano che si rispetti c'è sempre
un colpo di scena
Questo e voi credevate fosse soltanto una cartellina per tenere. I fogli in realtà è una lettera una lettera
Di milo manara che dopo aver visto. I suoi disegni devastati in questa serie
Ha giustamente, preso le distanze come sanno tutti quelli che si occupano. Di cinema di animazione
questi disegni
Sarebbero dovuti essere utilizzati come riferimento per la realizzazione delle animazioni vere e proprie purtroppo la decisione di utilizzarli non è stata mia
E a suo tempo non
Ho potuto che far presente la mia forza e perplessità in merito
Praticamente questi hanno preso le bozze
che milo manara fatto soltanto per dare un'idea del senso che avrebbe dovuto avere la serie e questo e quello studio secche le
Animate e questo spiega il perché di quei piccoli. Incubi ma anche sapendo questa
Cosa qua. Non basta a risollevare la serie che cala al
7,66 per cento con un milione e mezzo di spettatori in quattro puntate adrian scomparso
Dai palinsesti che fine farà lo show di celentano
Ufficialmente lo rinviano di una settimana per un malanno di stagione di adriano
guarda caso per la prossima settimana lo spostano al martedì perché lunedì ci sarebbe stato
Montalbano e si. Stavano pagando per la competizione o il martedì sarebbe poi iniziata la champions quindi decidono ragazzi
Loro inviamo. Di una settimana poi quella settimana diventano due e poi sparisce
Dai palinsesti cazzo lunghetto sto. Malanno di stagione
E qui finisce la tragica storia di un mistero italiano. Di una serie che sarebbe potuta diventare l'avanguardia
italiana e invece alla fine
Giace al fondo. Di una rupe esattamente come nell'episodio la rupe del silenzio
Di di fulmine e allora questa parte qua non. Ho neanche il copione perché voglio che sia il più sincera possibile
Adriano, uno scemo su internet cerca di spiegarsi il perché perché. Io io ero contento
Quando è uscita la serie non tanto perché fosse stata. Se sarebbe stato un disastro annunciato e quindi avrei
Riso da solo a casa mia non. Solo per quello ma perché
è incredibile
è stata una voce incredibile
Nella televisione tale va su canale 5 una cosa del genere fatta da un cantante dopo tanti tanti anni. Di carriera e credibile anche perché
tu combattevi con programmi tipo
Gees my age sto cazzo di programma
Con enrico papi che un programma semplicemente dove de la gente deve indovinare che età a una persona soltanto visiva
Ma che idea del cazzo. È sarebbe. Come fare un programma in prima serata
Su raiuno che chi tocca per ultimo lo attraversava in porta
No, non è un programma non è un coso programma quindi ero contento adriano ero contento veramente
Secondo me questa
Cosa qua non
Ha funzionato perché non si è capito per chi cazzo fosse stasera perché. I giovani erano
Interessati. Alla serie animata ma
Gente tipo. I miei genitori o la gente di 50 60 anni che ti adora da tanto tempo
da te ne frega un cazzo della serie animata adriano niente ne frega
e infatti
riguardavano soltanto il pre show mentre chi guardava la serie animata
Arriva da in questo decennio in cui tu hai fatto
Hai lavorato. Alla serie, c'è stato di tutto netflix, non. Netflix pirateria
internet e l'internet si è voluto tantissimo questi dieci anni
La tua è una serie che è nata vecchia. Ma. Vecchia veramente perché
la cosa peggiore
Di questa serie qui, non è tanto le animazioni non è tanto I disegni
Non è tanto che fosse trash non è tanto che fosse noiosa la parte iniziale
noi tanto che fossero banali monologhi e le battute e che
insulta
All'intelligence dello spettatore lo spettatore medio che usa internet
Come me. Come tutti. Che usiamo internet da anni perché quello che
Alcune persone. Su twitter e su facebook hanno scritto
Se vuoi ascoltaste un po di più la sera invece. Di criticare capireste quanti. Chiavi di lettura ci sono
Ma le chiavi di lettura. Di adria sono. Di una balena banalità sconcertante
adriano ti dico una cosa non cambiarla in autunno questa serie qua metterà su internet
I vigili etiopi gli autori vieni da noi
vieni da noi su internet che alla gente su internet azioni perché dopo una settimana c'è la
Settimana dove la gente poi se ne sbatte. I coglioni di quello che puoi fare una merda puoi fare
Uno show che non funziona. Una serie che non funziona le challenge cross marcia le puoi fare
Quello che vuoi poi la gente si incazza. Ma. Puglie. Ne frega
I coglioni non ci sono vertici mediaset che ti fanno cagare in mano non c'è bisogno. Di mostrare un certificato. Medico per dire
ragazzi purtroppo non ci sono
vieni su internet
Se uno ti vendo il mio spazio. Il mio spazio su youtube il mio canale
Così posso mettere un po più divido facciamo magari il martedì mettiamo. Adria
Che lunedi c'e montalbano quindi non si, sa mai e vieni fallo da me tanto. Chi cazzo me
ne frega un cazzo alla gente e quinta dopo tutto questo ti dico grazie per aver creato questa serie qui
Potevamo farne a meno però almeno ci hai provato
Abbiamo dato un occhio a quello che sarebbe potuto essere il futuro
grazie